what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are going to watch
today The Last of Us episode 6 Easter
eggs breakdown from the man himself poor
heavy spoilers joined of course ball
well friend Andrew Gordon hello there
eagles 7-Eleven hello uh I've never
actually met Paul but every time I hear
you do that impression I actually think
it's him so keep it up dude that's
impressive think I'm nailing it orange
you'll go ahead and leave a look sweep
your chimney all wheel or wheel to have
a small table check out our reaction for
episode six today alrighty groovy baby
yes I understood that reference go
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul in this video we're
breaking down episode 6 of The Last of
Us yes the latest entry is packed with
Easter eggs tons of callbacks to the
game and also a big Cliffhanger ending
that we're going to be explaining the
outcome of in this video we'll say that
until the end as always as it has some
major games spoilers in it I'll of
course give you a heads up before we hit
that section as always I'm excited for
this episode they do hit a part that
didn't actually get flashed out properly
until the second game I'm not gonna be
giving away any massive spoilers in
terms of the story but I think it's
important to talk about how it at least
looks similar to that so if you don't
want things like the ball we see in this
is the bar in the second game and I'm
sorry for spoiling it there I hope you
join us again next week see you chump
now the entry has a major reunion with
Tommy and Jackson and though this
happens in the first game they actually
have the reunion in the town that
appears in the second when you arrive
there in part one you were primarily at
a dam which the people of Jackson were
apparing to power the town we see this
location in the episode mode but we
don't get the shootout that happens
there in the game I do wish we did get
the damn brought to life because I love
the aesthetic and we haven't done
anything ringing from the game where you
have Ellie and water and then you put
her on some like palette a palette yeah
because in the game she's often oh I
can't swim so Joel has to uncomfortably
swim but dries off incredibly fast I
knew there was something missing in this
show and it was a palette that was it is
that's what everyone's collaborating but
I agree it would have been cool to see
the dam brought to life but at least we
did get to see an exterior shot which I
appreciated but I actually did just play
that level in the game and it's so much
fun I love that part you didn't Venture
into Jackson and it was only in party
that you saw the town for what it was
which is perfectly recaptured here now
in the game this section actually takes
place in the fall and thus there's none
of the snow that we see in this entry
however part two starts off in the
winter with a town covered in a vast
blanket of it and you even have a
snowball fight early on to learn the
mechanics of the game snowball fight
reference later on in the episode when
we get of the town we can see some kids
playing in the background yeah they
bumped the timeline of the shop to
recapture the look of snowy Jackson and
there's several landmarks there that
we'll talk about later on in the video
also it's important to bear in mind that
in the game the community hadn't really
been set up yet which is why you were
creating a power source through
repairing the dam now we pick up with a
flashback to last week in which Henry
took his own life after shooting Sam in
the game you immediately cut to Black
after that and I think they went back to
this in the intro to mirror in the show
Henry
Henry no
oh my God
we didn't point this out last time on
the on the show but when Henry does what
does the YouTube say for unalive himself
I did I like it more in that episode
because we got to like see Ellie's
reaction and really focus on that and I
actually thought I made it more
impactful to breathe in that moment and
see the burial just a little side side
bit right there
but that does mirror the game we get an
immediate time Jump and The Last of Us
did this after several deaths most
notably saris on the HBO podcast for the
show they said that they added in the
burial scene to show how much Joe had
now become apparent Joel was in the
camera that would stick around and bury
the dead but he did this for Ellie so
that she could grieve and grow there was
ah yes that was easy because no one's
relying on them but Ali had Sam very
much relying on her Neil druckman said
that Joel remained at the grave because
he realized he couldn't go through the
this again and after watching another
kid die like Sarah he struggled with
getting attached to Ellie now we also
see some Dead Rabbits being taken in and
the winter chapter of the game start off
with one hopping along before was then
shot by an arrow with Ellie
that's the cutest part
[Music]
we know from the Catalyst that the
characters called marlin played by
Graeme green this is actually a new
character for the show along with his
wife Florence he discovers that Joel has
her gunpoint and they've been living out
in the wilderness together the whole set
up here seems pretty alien to what he'd
come across in the game and I think
they've done this to sort of Mirabelle
and Frank we have an elderly couple that
have managed to stay together through
the apocalypse and carve out what's
likely been a relatively peaceful life
you know what I like about having that
tidbit in there because as you know a
world that has experienced the pandemic
recently there were a lot of us who were
like ah
dream come true never have to leave and
keep away from everyone else so I
actually feel like including that with
Bill and then this couple here actually
makes it feel a little bit more
relatable yeah no I actually did like
that inclusion it was a good expansion
and just also too I like that
interaction that they had with Joel and
Ellie as well and I like those uh
batting that they had with those two
characters what I got from that is you
liked it I liked it that's what I got
the scene is played for laughs and we
quickly realized that giolin Ali are
terrible at and Tara gang now this is
actually riffing on a scene yeah that
uses the same tactics but it's way more
bloody in this Source material oh yeah
Jill says we're somewhere here exactly
where and your answer better be the same
as your wife he's torturing
[Applause]
come on
the market on the map and it better be
the same exact spot your buddy points to
I really love that scene in the game
we're definitely gonna work in this
scene but perhaps a future event for
when that scene comes up having a moment
like that I think is really important
for Joel because I think it even
demonstrates more of just how far he's
willing to go in the Name of Love the
Way how Craig Mason has talked about
with this series because yeah he gets
like very as you saw in that clip very
violently emotionally aggressive yeah
and just to clarify when I said
expansion that's what I meant on the
interrogation because this was a
different form of interrogation when
they had another scene with the care if
the actor from Dance With The Wolves and
also fun tidbit I wonder if they do have
this scene in the show wouldn't it be
interesting if that is played by Troy
Baker like in the show that'd be cool
like what the hell yeah I love that
Marlon also has a bow and arrow and this
is a weapon that you use throughout the
game to stay stealthy he brings up Cody
and this is the location that y'all
thought Tommy was located at earlier in
the season
and thus it makes sense why they moved
from there Joel's been desperately
searching for his brother since then and
this is why he's had to resort to
holding up two lovely lovely people in a
cabin who always probably hit the Thumbs
Up Button now with them comes an ominous
warning not to cross the river she never
go past the river here what's past the
river death
oh in Jackson they play up that they use
his reputation to keep out stragglers
but I actually think they might be
teasing some people from the game that
will definitely about the super spoiler
section section definitely anyway they
haven't heard of the fireflies and
outside Joel has to take a rest we don't
really learn what this is but the last
couple of months have been hell on him
and this comes full circle at the end of
the episode this is a new edition for
the series and Joel didn't deal with any
of the health problems that we see him
getting here he did however get stabbed
like what happens in the end though this
was on some rebar instead of the
Hunter's weapons anyway they head out
after taking one of her rabbits and this
is slung up on Ali's
Backpacker to her horse they set out
across the landscape and I love shots
like this where you actually get to see
the beauty of it reminds you of just how
long this journey is and how far they
have to travel they go from cities to
forests and mountain ranges and the game
did this too with it constantly feeling
like you were never in the same place
for too long
and they've reached the river of death
and decide to pump go down for the night
we see Joel applying duct tape to his
Boot and this is something that he of
course did a test in episode 2. although
this scene doesn't appear in the game it
was actually originally meant to and
this moment is based on Concepts oh no
way that's like Star Wars [__] around
the campfire and shared stories like
what we see here when discussing it Neil
druckman said that was a moment we
couldn't make work in the game so that
was a conversation ahead with Craig on
how do we capture these downbeat moments
thanks for coming on the show there Neil
I actually hope they do that a lot more
I never even suspected that the game had
a deleted scene because it's a video
game my mind never Ventures like it's a
video game you can include whatever the
hell they want and after playing last of
us too it looks like they included
whatever the hell they want because the
game's like 50 hours long that's like a
almost akin to kind of like what
Mandalorian does when they bring in
deleted scenes or concept art and
actually bring it to uh I've uh played
the first game many times and I've done
a lot of research and I never even knew
that that was a possible deleted scene
or they had concept art for it so that
was a really equal to the Paul and
congrats on getting Neil druckman on
your channel that was awesome now the
Pez dishes returned from the camping
scene in episode 4 and they share a
drink with Ellie doing the usual face
she'd pull anytime you had some alcohol
still gross 14 which I I never did
anything like that at least starts to
think about the future and he talks
about what they're gonna do after the
Cure is made but she does have a line in
there maybe it's in his super spoiler
section and he doesn't want to say it I
hope it is I'm gonna bring it up later
though Greg pointed that out immediately
as it happened come on Paul you gotta be
better man you didn't even tease that
it's gonna be in the Super spoilery
section we're judging you if you don't
put that in there that could be a line
possibly in that possible thing you're
talking about just saying people are
like what the hell is Grandma like
probably like what are we both talking
about I don't even know what we're
talking about the pair of being so
focused on getting to the Firefly so
they haven't thought Beyond it but yeah
they really start to look towards the
future Joe says he wants an old
farmhouse where he'll race
along with what Ellie says you won't
spoil until the end of the video again
and say with me super spoiler
that's not in space will likely have a
payoff too anyway Alex is that she
rubbed her blood onto Sam deceiver would
save him and it clearly has a doubting
whether she's actually the Savior I
tried it the other day it doesn't work
said and we've talked about this in our
prior breakdowns he does this whenever
he thinks about Sarah and it happened
before they just reached the Boston
State Building I would love to see an
interview without Pedro Pascal and ask
when you weren't actually filming or
were just in your trailer could you
always have that watch you know where
the actors often do some type of like
proper physical motifs that help them
stay in character or stay in the mood oh
if he had a hard time channeling Joel he
would like look at the watch and then
you know activate a memory something
like that I wonder if that's already out
there because that sounds like it it
would be really cool to if he actually
did the like walking in Phoenix for
Johnny Cash would always carry the
guitar around with him because he felt
like it was an extension of his
character and I wonder if that was
something that Pedro Pascal also did
citizens of the reject Nation we are
asking you to message Pedro Pascal and
to get him on an interview with the real
reason well I would love that like let's
talk about Mandalorian instead no let's
talk about Wonder Woman 1984. let's go
to the Law and Order episode
eagle and Stan on his watch and this is
something that was then carried over to
the show when he was watching Henry and
Ali play football he also did it then
and I love how this Motif keeps
reappearing throughout the series
obviously the watch doesn't work and
it's more of a reminder of the life he
lost however it's also shown that Ellie
could be a second chance for him to be a
dad and he switches in his moment to be
nicer towards her he reassures her that
Molly knows what she's doing and we can
clearly see a major change in Joel it's
also important bear in mind that they
don't mind starting a fire here rise in
episode 4 they of course avoided doing
it Hunters wouldn't really be out this
far as they tended to stick near the
cities and the infected also froze when
they were in these conditions in part
two you come across some Frozen stiff
and they very much tend to stick to
warmer areas slept in and Ellie's taking
the second shift showing how much more
independent she's becoming she carries
his rifle and in the game of the hotel
Joel ended up giving this to her so she
could provide sniper cover as he took
out Hunters the podcast for the series
talked about the scene in which he gave
her the gun in episode 4 and this was
very much a moment of Joel becoming a
father once more like any parent that
he's giving a child a skill that they
feel they can now do on their own and
this Ellie's taking it upon herself to
Stan god with the gun give kids guns
deafness is clearly putting them in a
vulnerable position in episode 1 he
didn't hear Tess coming in when he was
asleep we had the whole thing with Henry
and Sam and now he's not even hearing
Ellie getting up you can see Stoner Dan
himself and at the end he doesn't hear
the hunter sneaking up on them they make
their way across a bridge and once more
we assume that this is the river of
death I think we will see something like
this in episode 7 and finally get that
sweet sweet River of death that's right
Metal Gear Solid three that was not
Metal Gear Solid three what was that was
that this I think the smell of your saw
three is it snake isn't that metal gear
oh yeah anyway what does it matter are
there any characters in the game who are
deaf not that I remember because that
has been a prevalent inclusion in here
with Sam and now with Joel like the
sense of sound is so integral to the
experience of the video game itself
because you you do have to always abide
by the rules of sound in that game that
it is interesting to have
um characters that we focus on we
struggle with their own hearing and how
detrimental that can be to survival in
this world I like to really quickly that
they added that for Joel just because in
the game he really feels Invincible like
so you know giving him a deficiency like
that too it kind of it makes him more
feel more vulnerable for more you know
it humanizes him a little more so I
think it was a good add-on I think this
was Metal Gear Solid 3. okay I'm glad we
straightened that up with the whole
comment section would have been littered
with that was the wrong game you guys
mentioned we also get a play on the
scene from the game when Ellie tries to
whistle
I'm learning how to whistle you don't
know how to whistle neither do I Ellie
really really don't
[Music]
are you all right
something for you to annoy me with you
don't know how to whistle does it sound
like I know how to whistle
they then come across the aforementioned
Hydro Dam which was a location you had
to navigate to get past Ellie couldn't
swim and you had to jump in the water
and use a board to navigate her so she
could build a bridge for you on the
other side of this he came across a
child's grave and this was potentially
played upon last week ah yes
and this was the guy who wrote The
Amazing five-star reviewed pun book and
after guessing wrongly that this is the
river of death again I'm starting to
think Ellie should start saying through
time for the amount of [__] talks anyway
the ambushed by people on Horseback with
their guns drawn dogs are brought in to
smell if they're infected and in Jackson
he actually got to pet one when you were
going through the dam that's Buckley not
much of a guard dog
maybe good to have around
that's a good boy now in facing off a
group of enemies a lot of them would
also carry dogs and they'd sniff you out
as you moved about areas yeah
and thus it doesn't have the government
technology like this scan as we saw in
episode one so they have to use dogs to
smell cordyceps but it doesn't flag up
an alley probably because it's been
nullified or it's mutated in here
for the first time who we learn is
Tommy's wife she gets a far more fleshed
out role here and in the first game he
just had a couple of words with her here
and there when you arrived at the dam
and she's white in the game but black in
the show is everyone too scared to point
it out not Greg no I'm not
I'm not
the shock she adds an extra Dimension to
that relationship and they make her
pregnant which is something that wasn't
in the game at all now they hit the
front gate and these are modeled to look
exactly the same as how they appear at
the start of part two in that yeah
of course also how they get in here as
the end of the town we see two signs and
the first of these is the Lights
Festival this was advertised for 2003
which again is a reminder of when the
world collapsed in the show Jackson was
lit up with lights for part two and this
came off the back of the Hydra Dam that
you held to power up in part one we
later on see these being used as lights
through the town at night and this signs
a nice bit of foreshadowing to set that
whole thing up now to the right we can
also see the Tipsy Tipsy button the
location that two appeared in part two
and this is very much just the creative
team laying the groundwork for what's
coming we'll talk about what happens
there in the spoiler section but I did
warn you that'd be things like that the
bar is the same as the other bot now
ruin the second game she writes in the
first is a woman in a wheelchair chair
and the second is a bunch of kids at
school in the game the reason that Henry
and Sam fight Hartford is because one's
Federer abandoned their posts they often
fell into the hands of Raiders who
refused to care for kids of the elderly
yeah though we see the jacksonites will
look after the weekend and firm and it
shows what kind of civilization that
they're trying to build as you mentioned
in the game and Joel bloody Joel he was
actually the more optimistic one
thinking they could make a new world
maybe you don't have to or maybe you
don't have to be now Joel sees Tommy
working on some scaffolding and this
changes things up from how it happens in
the game
[Music]
don't even think about reaching for your
weapon tell the girl to drop hers now
Ellie
it was the lady says
[Music]
we didn't know the place was occupied
we're just trying to make our way
through through to where
they're all right but you know these
people
know him
[Music]
he's my goddamn brother
Tommy
[Music]
I wish they spoke Spanish in the show
holy [__]
Hermano
how you doing baby brother he kind of
combined the guns being drawn and Tommy
being amongst them whereas in the show
we get the Riders and then them taking
them in as I keep mentioning this
happened at the time because Jackson was
in a location they'd made for the game
and damn it's gonna get annoying when I
keep pointing that out but on we go
we've been here just a week it feels
like forever yeah it makes sense to me
that the reunion would feel entirely
different uh between them especially
because in the game itself you know that
they're they've grown distant and uh it
seems like they ended on not a good note
where here in the show they're still in
contact and he's like I haven't been
able to hear from my brother I keep in
contact with him regularly no text
messages no FaceTime calls none of it's
working right now so it makes sense that
their reunion would be a lot more
heartfelt and emotional versus like as
you saw here there's like as much as he
still missed they still missed each
other you still feel a gap between them
right I mean as you just pointed out
there was difference of reasons like
whereas in the game you know they had a
falling out whereas here he hadn't heard
from him in a while so it makes sense
you know why you have that difference I
like what they did here uh having the
Riders and then we get the reveal of
Maria and I really like that actress a
lot from True Blood uh that plays her
and I like how they fleshed out Maria a
lot more in this and they made her
pregnant so it adds a lot more Stakes
for Tommy's character too obviously we
don't want anything to happen to Tommy
but the fact that he's got a kid on the
way just adds more tension and Stakes
for his character true true
notice he didn't mention she was black
now the official HBO podcast brought up
that Joe very much has it within him
that he needs to protect his family and
going back to the conversation in the
truck there were hints towards this she
all talked about how he only followed
Tommy because he wanted to keep him
alive I think this is very much the same
in the case of Ellie and he's the kind
of person who needs to be a protective
father figure this is you to Sarah's
core belief his personality he now
thinks that he has to protect his family
no matter the cost they end up hugging
which appears in both the showing game
and she all says he's came here to save
him he is of course starting to believe
in the vaccine and as far as they're
concerned they're on a quest to save the
world I like what happens in the game
they're offered food by Maria well we
bring him inside
yeah
you hungry
starving wow you get a Chow Down in a
problem and we get what I think is a
cameo from a character that pops up in
part two we'll discuss it later on have
you seen what's going on with Ellie who
doesn't act like the rest of the kids
injects 100 on the camera yeah announced
they're married and it kind of goes back
to this moment from the game Maria is
Family actually
oh [__] congrats
ma'am thanks for not pulling my head off
would have been embarrassing considering
you're my brother-in-law
[Music]
we all got to get wrangled up at some
point now they get a tour of that more
foreshadowing for season two and we see
sheep tying back to the farm that gel
talked about around the campfire it
seems like the perfect home for them and
Ellie meets the horse Shimmer which is
also the name of the horse that she
writes in the game come on that's not
really spoiling stuff she has a horse
anyway I love the realization of Tommy
realizing that they're pretty much
communist he of course had this view of
the world but in order to survive he's
had to alter his principles to fit it
also before you start calling the
Authority for British values or whatever
I'm not a communist I think it's
interesting how he's had to adapt to a
different way of life to survive I'm
guessing that they're trying to say that
fedra and the Raiders are capitalists as
they're all out for themselves and
trying to exploit people but we're
getting a bit deeper on the political
theories there anyway they hit the Tipsy
bison and told me not political because
the machine probably uses too much power
his old place is covered in snow as well
so they can just scrub it from there
it's a bit of an icy reception and I see
it's clearly uneasy between the pair and
we get some stuff that pulls from the
game it doesn't seem like you age much
you while you're there let me look at
you
[Music]
you're [__] old
easy it's gonna happen to you too and
the kid
oh yeah she's the daughter of some
Firefly monkey mug you're almost be
important
[Music]
so you know where they might be these
fireflies why bring her here I was
supposed to deliver to the fireflies
the way I figure they're your boys you
finish the job you collect the whole
damn pain I haven't seen a firefly in
years no they got a base down at the
University of Eastern Colorado
it's a week's Ride Shop what makes you
think I'd do this for you this isn't for
me Tommy this is for your damn cause my
cause is my family now you ain't talking
about some walk in the park here Jesus
boy
have Maria get some of your born-again
friends and do it they got families too
Maria's a few months along now
so I just got to be more careful now
we've often talked about how Joe pushes
things to the back of his mind so he
doesn't have to face the truth or
inflict pain on others in the game he
refused to tell Bella Tessa died and
even kept it the lie that she was back
in Boston
what kind of trouble are you in
where the hell is that
this is the job simple drop off
so you didn't answer my question
yeah I thought the two of you were
inseparable
she's busy I was like there's trouble in
Paradise busy foreign
might be trouble in Paradise
oh yes nicely it is the same thing here
and pretends that everything's all good
with her so how's this
she's fine I think he does this because
talking about her death means that he
has to acknowledge it happen and with
this brings the pain of their Lawson
also the feeling that he's failed at the
damn in the game rather than talking
about tests Tommy brought up Sarah he
said he'd actually gone back to where
they lived in Texas to visit their old
home he picked up a photo but Joel
didn't even really want to look at it
and he dismissed it pretty quickly
it's a little faded but it still looks
pretty good
I'm good
you sure I mean I said I'm good again
this is the character completely broken
but refusing to accept it because he
doesn't want to deal with the pain that
comes with loss he lies and says that he
was heading this way and just so
happened to pass by Jackson well we know
that he's been searching with Tommy for
months and months and months yeah I love
that the show actually takes the time to
really unpack that significantly more if
there's one thing this show can do and
take the opportunity to while sometimes
they skip over some awesome gameplay
moments I think they really double down
on more of the emotional beats in the
character exploration and it's something
that makes Joel who's you know he's an
archetype Joel in the game he's an
archetype and he's great though he's
amazed don't get me wrong like I love
the hell out of Joel one of my favorite
video game characters ever but here they
make him far more than just the
archetype of guy with a hardened past
who now refuses to accept his emotions
he's he's someone who fights against
breaking down but is on the verge of it
constantly yeah I agree and also I like
that Paul just showed that scene that we
didn't get in terms of him showing the
picture Tommy rather showing Joel the
picture of Sarah which I think is going
to circle back to a scene that I won't
mention when we get to the spoilers
section here I'm going to bring that
back don't worry I won't forget about
that good good so I gotta bring up
something you gotta bring up something
guys we we're gonna bring up so many
something plan all along was together
here but we see in the end that he
accepts she's his responsibility now we
really see the difference between Tommy
and John at this point when they discuss
what they had to do to survive they're
very protective of this place you have a
good [__] reason I mean folks find
out we're up here no I heard
wrong people might show up
so is that what I am by the wrong people
this is how you gonna repay me huh repay
you for all those goddamn years I took
care of us all the things I did tell me
those things that you judge me for I did
those things to Keep Us Alive we did
those things took care that's what you
call it
I got nothing but nightmares from those
years you survived because of me it
wasn't worth it they weren't things
we murdered people
oh
I bring you the Cure from Mankind and
you want to play the pissy little
brother
and I don't judge you for it
we survive the only way we knew how
there were other ways
we ain't back in Boston
you lay your hands on me again it won't
end well for you
we'll grab some supplies and be out of
your hair in the morning
[Music]
Tommy sees it as measuring people rise
gel sees it as being summing that he had
to do to survive that's something again
that I like to acknowledge whenever I
find that they replicate scenes but they
feel different based off of the kind of
scene work and Prelude into it because I
love the way how Pedro Pascal chose to
play those lines of dialogue because you
know Troy Baker's that version works so
well in that moment in the game he's
defensive and angry whereas Pedro Pascal
when he is saying those lines to him you
get the defensive part but you get more
of the hurt part like you are judging
before this and you're not appreciating
anything for me and now you're really
judging me to my core when I did this
for you as well you know so I like that
he plays more on the pain of that versus
the defense mechanism of just anger yeah
and also too you got a different side
version of Tommy on the show as well
where he's like he was being a little
more understanding and I mean obviously
saying like yeah it was terrible what we
did but I don't judge you for it you
know so yeah I appreciated that they had
that more
it's a Latino understanding Joe
selfishness and need to keep things that
he wants is something that's a theme
which repeats throughout the story but
in all honesty I think most of us would
have done the same thing people would
like to think that the good guys who
would make sacrifices if the time call
free but a lot of us will happily step
on others to keep going definitely very
much represents the true face of
humanity Raz Tommy wants to be something
better now this new outlook has likely
been brought on by the fact that he's
gonna be a father in that relationship
before the outbreak Joe was the one with
the kid Raz Tommy was the one with no
responsibilities he'd be the one off
down the bars starting fights and
showing up to his brother's house
looking for breakfast yeah though he's
not the father and the one who is seen
as being the father is left without a
kid Sarah was supposed to have so much
ahead of her but this was Rob from both
her and Joel for this worse World Tommy
says just because life stopped for you
doesn't mean it has to stop for me and
this is of course reflected in his watch
which stopped the second Sarah was shut
now outside things get too much for him
again and he ends up having to rest
again all this is new for the show with
it not really appearing in the game I
think when you're playing is the
character you don't really think of
health problems and stuff because you're
very much them however giola's in his
50s and he's been traveling on the road
for months and months with very little
rest and food he's sleeping in on the
mornings having to take his time and
slowly going down and there is a big
physical talk chicken anymore and this
adds a lot to the character he also sees
someone that he believes is Sarah all
grown up I'm sure anyone who's ever lost
somebody can relate to this moment and
you often do see strangers that you
think could be the person even if it's
impossible Joel has a brief moment where
he forgets everything's lost and it's
almost like he's seeing Sarah grown up
happy with the life she should have had
it's pretty devastating and explains why
he wants to hold on to Ellie now from
here we go to Ali who's home up in a
child's room the pictures on the wall
and color in general are of course meant
to evoke Sarah's from episode 1 and
we're slowly seeing the two become more
similar and similar later on when Jill
comes in we see a giraffe poster on the
wall mimicking the giraffe toy that
appeared in Sarah's room in the game it
also walked past swan in episode 2 and
giraffes are very important so keep an
eye out stream also has a really great
poster in and we can catch Creep by
Radiohead this is a song about being an
outsider not feeling like you belong and
it's very much representative of how
Ellie feels they also hate that song
there were several obviously owned by
people who died on outbreak day that
people ended up filling this is very
much the case here and Ellie gets a note
saying I'm across the street this is
written on her made paper which I
remember having to do back in Primary
School in some art and craft lesson
obviously in this world so if they want
to make notes like this they have to
either get some paper from 2003 or make
their own we next touching a purple and
white hoodie and this is what she wore
from the damn pot onwards now lastly
it's a cap to deal with her periods and
we of course saw her looking for one in
episode 3 which was her risking her life
I'm not no expert on this stuff but with
it being rubber I'm guessing it's
reusable so she won't have to go into
any basements anymore now Joel's a man
so he probably doesn't think about these
kinds of things and that's why it's
given by Maria Ali goes to her house and
this looks similar to the layout of some
of the houses that you'd come across
when walking around Jackson thousand
percent I think in a moment that's a
pretty big gut punch once you realize
what it is on a chalkboard we see two
names with a set of dates below them
this belongs to Kevin and Sarah and this
is very much the pair's gravestone to
mark their passing now Kevin's a new
character for the show and we see that
he died at the age of three wow two days
after the outbreak we learned Kevin was
Maria's child and it shows why she makes
a bond with hair whilst also showing why
Maria doesn't want Tommy running off
Maria instantly goes into motherly mode
and makes sure that she has a code to
keep keep her warm she also cuts her
hair and if you've ever played The
Walking Dead Telltale Game then you'll
know he did a similar thing in that with
Clementine so that she couldn't get
grabbed by the undead we learned that
Maria was okay interesting explains why
she's kind of shifted into being a
sheriff she's clearly accepted the loss
of her child and she's a complete
opposite to Joel due to the fact that
she's happy to talk about Kevin it's at
this point that Ellie learns about Sarah
and suddenly the penny drops one thing I
love about the podcast is that they
really delved deep into the fact that
Ellie's looking for a parental figure
just as much as Joel is looking for a
surrogatory this is why Ali smiled when
he beat up the soldier in episode 1 and
why she said last week that she was
scared of being alone now the two very
much had his father-in-law relationship
but in this world it'll lead to them
enabling the other to carry out terrible
things this was very apparent in the
brine scene in which Ellie allowed Joel
to murder him Neil druckman said that in
any other show a movie that she would
try and plead for Brian's life because
killing him was the the evil thing to do
what about Ellie knows that Joel has to
do it unless she just walked away with
her back turned she's clearly defensive
of Joel and won't let Maria badmouth him
warn her about what she all's really
like now Ellie clearly ends up feeling
betrayed by Joel's planet ditch here and
in her mind she built up that he was
gonna be her dad we see this reflected
in the next scene in which we occur to
the people of Jackson watching the movie
The goodbye girl that's what it is
often in the city and there was one that
was gonna happen during the Super
spoiler section which we'll talk about
later anyway the movie actually has a
lot of allusions to what's going on in
this story right now it involves a
single mother moving into an apartment
with her daughter and her active
boyfriend Tony he gets a job in Italy
and he ends up subletting the apartment
to a man named Elliot who's played by
Richard Dreyfus the Mother Paula and he
stood a relationship and over time the
daughter Lucy becomes attached to Elliot
whether he gets a job in Seattle and
Lucy worries the same thing is gonna
happen with him that happened at Tony
this is of course reflected
like all the other people in her life so
far she's had several parental figures
including Federer Moline Tess and Joel
and the boy the last one they've all
been people she's left behind I
understood their reference yeah I
understood it too because of the game
it's called Left Behind I get it or are
you talking about the Bible movies both
yes my Jewish friend he believes in
Revelations over here I like the way the
show handles this seeking surrogates
because it feels very much like
subconscious choices which is more real
life like you don't have Ellie going out
there being like I'm looking for a
parental figure you know because kids
don't say that [__] neither is Joel but
you can see that they are actually
seeking that whether or not they admit
it to themselves and I feel like they
really capture the humanity of that very
very well and realistic as well
absolutely and also too I I mentioned in
this episode after we uh reacted to it I
really did love that scene because with
Maria and with Ellie we didn't get that
scene in the game and it just expands
upon what was talked about in the game
but we didn't get to see and just shows
how defensive Ellie can be of Joel and
just again that that surrogacy that you
just mentioned like you really feel like
she is daughter especially in moments
like that where it just feels real like
you really feel the gut punch of when
Joel is gonna ditch her and she how hurt
she is by that like moments like that
just add to that for me
never mention that Maria
oh and Maria
um is a good actress a jaw ditching her
in the next scene is a mirror of how
Lucy felt in the film in the end Elia
takes the job and it seems like he's
gonna be gone forever but he asks Paula
to restring the guitar that he left yeah
wow this is very much The Last of Us
right and it ends on a more hopeful note
just like how Joel decides to take Ellie
Joel is also a king guitar player too
and I love the similarities between this
film and The Arc in the episode no joke
Last of Us was my first PS4 game and
when you have to play the guitar I
thought I could not beat this game
because I did not understand whatever
the center but it is oh yeah that's
where you strum from yeah yeah and I
spent a solid 20 minutes
call Andrew what do I do I had to go on
Google and be like how does this work
and then I couldn't find it and then I
called Olivia over and she's like I
think you have to look immediately she
got it I'm like Oh my crack of hitting
every button and the joystick in the
back I guess you learned a new thing
every day because I never knew this
story and I never knew that Last of Us
Part Two was your first game on ps4 mine
was Destiny which a fun game but uh you
know I like Last of Us Part Two a little
bit more but I probably would have given
you a couple minutes of just let me see
how long a big screen figure this out
that's awesome I can just visualize this
now now Ali knows his Tommy leaving and
we curded y'all at a workbench trying to
fix his shoe work with adventures in the
game away you do upgrades at but yeah
they set the scene for a difficult
conversation between Joe and his brother
Tommy brings him some new boots and
apologizes for going off before which is
when they launch into a really deep
moment this ball is somewhat from the
game and in that they kind of combine
the Boss scene with what we get here
she's immune mewno what
what
really
she got infected but she didn't get sick
I know I've seen her breathe enough
spores to take down a dozen men and
nothing
I wouldn't have believed it neither
but I can show you that's hard to bit
myself
that was months ago months
she's in me all right
I'll bite why bring her here
supposed to deliver through the
fireflies
the way I figure they're your boys you
finish the job you collect the whole
damn payment I haven't seen a firefly in
years you know where they are it was
Marlene
she hired us to smuggle her to some
fireflies
what makes you think I'd do this for you
you want me to take her I'm just gonna
get her killed I know it
I'll take that girl years to the
fireflies
you don't have to worry about it I'll
take her out of dawn
maybe some real good will come of this
[Music]
I kind of like her more in the show
because it's it's such a hard decision
and takes such a toll on him for to hand
over Ellie to Tommy to uh deliver
instead of him other than that they just
also they established the it's PTSD
right that he as would you say I think
he has like a uh minor anxiety disorder
anxiety PTSD whatever it is but yeah
yeah because they established that and
then the loss that he's incurred and he
just feels he's gonna fail after what's
happened with Tess with Henry and Sam
with Sarah he just doesn't want to go
through that again and even though it's
a very hard decision because they've
established that so much and obviously
it was inferred in the game like it's
very similar the way it's executed in
the show it's just like you can see in
the way Pedro Pascal emotes it's just
it's really well done execute and also
too really quickly because I'm a little
slow I didn't even pick up until we just
saw the replay of that because they
don't have spores in the in the TV show
include the bite they had to get they
had to include the second bite because
so he could say that line because
because he couldn't say well she's
breathing in enough sports because that
wouldn't have made sense in the show so
obviously it makes sense that they had
her get bitten the second time thinking
the same thing yeah Joe tells his
brother the story of how they got there
and he goes over Brian in episode four
he's realized he's too old for this and
it makes Joel reevaluate what kind of
impact he's gonna have on Ellie she's
had to shoot someone because of his
actions and he also froze when Henry had
the gun pointed at him he feels like
she's better off with someone else and
the death of his daughter clearly still
weighs over him he says he's weak that
fear is causing his heart issues and
overall he's plagued with nightmares of
what could go wrong this is decided
y'all that we've never seen before and
watching Pedro cry brings a whole new
layer to the character yeah in the game
he was very sure and determined Raz here
we see how broken he is I think losing a
child in the way he did would make you
doubt yourself so much and with another
kid being entrusted him he just feels
like he can't measure her Tommy accepts
the job but as we learn Ellie listened
to this conversation and she's
heartbroken because of it she's a
[__] idiot though isn't she Ellie
every everyone Hey sir what do you mean
she's behind me
now in the game Tommy doing this caused
Maria to kick off and it was at this
moment that Ellie grabbed a horse and
left
if anything anything at all happens to
him it's on you yeah it's a lot more
subtle and Tommy returns to the
screening and Maria instantly knows
what's going on there's no words between
them and it's a really nice moment in
which you can see her having to deal
with the fact that her child's father's
putting great act on the line great
acting yeah yo wait what is it that girl
of yours she took one of our horses and
rode off which way come on I just saw
her riding on out of here go back inside
help the others clean the place up okay
call us now in the game when Ellie ran
off you had a bit where you followed her
horse tracks until you found her holed
up in a house on the way you fought some
Raiders just to vary the moments up
because you know after all you are
playing a game
had a heart to heart in an upstairs
bedroom like what happens here I'm just
going to combine the locations to make
the bedroom Ellie's bedroom and like I
keep saying Jackson was in the first
game so this house this house scene
couldn't have happened it couldn't have
another Dam
it's one of the best scenes in the game
no losses
this really all they had to worry about
is this really all they had to worry
about
boys movies
deciding which shirt goes with which
skirt
boys movies
deciding which shirt goes with which
skirt
bizarre it's bizarre
Tommy knows this area
I'm sorry I trust him better than better
than I trust myself stop with the
[__] I made this decision
you're way better off with Tommy oh what
Maria told me about Sarah Ellie
you are treading awesome Mighty thin
eyes here I'm not her you know
Maria told me about Sarah and no
I'm sorry about your daughter Joel
I've lost people too I'm sorry about
your daughter Joel
and I've lost people too
loss is
you have no idea what loss is
everyone I have cared for has either
died or left me
[Music]
everybody I have cared for
has either died or left me
[Music]
for you
everybody [__] except for you
so don't tell me that I would be safer
with someone else because the truth is I
would just be more scared
so don't tell me tell me safe with
somebody else because the truth is I
would just be more scared
[Music]
you're not my daughter you're
you're not my daughter
[Music]
and I sure as hell ain't your dad
sure as hell ain't your dad yeah you
can't you can't change the scene
except for that part yeah
we're going our separate ways
[Music]
and if I say no
do you even realize what your life means
listen why are you here
I came here to talk to you no why are
you still here well I guess we're both
disappointed with each other then
what do you want from me admit that you
wanted to get rid of me the whole time
after this moment we see Joel thinking
back to Sarah he remembers them
decorating the tree at Christmas and we
get a long shot focused on a dove and
this symbolically means peace off things
that gels live without for quite some
time and he clearly has a change of
heart as he's waiting at the stables for
Ellie unlike the game he gives her a
choice of who to go with but she
immediately chooses him I think this is
why he ends up collapsing at the end but
beyond the Stab Wound because it's very
much his worst fear coming true he felt
like he'd be a liability and that he
couldn't protect it this is kind of
proven right because you're definitely
does leave her in a very vulnerable
position come the final scene now they
say their goodbyes which takes us into
the university section is two pulled
from the game and it was at this point
that we learned more about Joel's past
in which he wanted to be a singer this
two is reflected in the scene when they
arrive whoa when I was a kid I wanted to
be a singer
why is that funny
bro when I was a kid I used to want to
be uh
a singer
shut up it was serious sing something uh
no come on I won't laugh I don't think
so Joel please
you're gonna sing something now no come
on now I'm not gonna laugh you're
already laughing okay I like the change
of beat in that because in the game
Joe's like so apprehensive of telling
her it's like I wanted to be a
singer pause and then uh in the show
he's he's just kind of like available
well I wanted to be a singer yeah and
then she laughs at him which makes him
close back up about him talking about it
more I think it's like a nice change of
beat because like the same almost the
same lines I like the mix-up of how they
do it with emotionality yeah and was the
camera angle a little bit different too
where where it was when I mean well
aren't you controlling the camera in the
game in that moment usually you're from
behind when it's uh because you're
controlling the horse whereas here we
can actually clearly see the actor's
face either way he's clearly stunned
interest Ali more and we see them
practicing with a makeshift shooting
range these moments are obviously
because he doesn't know how reliable
he's gonna be unless he wants her ready
for the dangers she could face a thing
from this point onwards that there's a
real chain
relationship with them bonding a lot
more everybody loves contractors anyway
they reached the university so and Ellie
points out the mascot like what we get
in the game
[Music]
what does that mean team mascot
that's a giant Ram
you guys are like some Idol worshipers
when it came to sports
hell yeah uh you want to come across
some monkeys like what we see in the
episode
are those monkeys nothing from the old
Labs look at them go I thought that was
a Jumanji reference and those monkeys
yeah a whole mess of them
now the game had you realizing that the
fireflies had abandoned the place
because there was infected there I won't
find you had to drop down into some of
the dorms which were teaming with
clickers in a blood and a blower
[Music]
is that they've skipped over a majority
of these scenes which really stand out
my memory yeah Skyscraper the hotel and
now this which I think are the things I
think are first when looking back to the
game seeing how well they handle the
clickers in episode 2 it made me really
excited for moments like this but
unfortunately they again skip over them
in the favor of other things possible
that they were infected here as we do
see sandbags piled high blocking one of
the doorways and that could explain why
they moved on but there's no 10 scenes
like that either way the outcome's the
same and we see some Firefly symbols
spray painted on a sign before they
reach the biochemical lapse inside this
you found x-rays in scans of the
infected and discovered that this was
where they'd been trying to manufacture
the vaccine having this would of course
give the fight fireflies a lot of power
as they'd be able to distribute it to
who they see fit and thus they could
very much decide who lives and who dies
now firstly Jill and Ali enter a main
hallway and this looks similar to where
Jill collapsed in the game in that you
were ambushed by Bandits and he was
impaled by some rebar after wrestling
with one and falling off a balcony gel
and Ali find a list and this is similar
the ones you'd come across in the game
when visiting the Aries this University
was the one they modeled the game after
as the environments are so similar down
to the staircase in the rooms they also
bring across the moment in which you
think the infected might be inside and
this is revealed to just be some monkiss
yes
the monkeys were very important to have
around as they're of course similar to
humans on a genetic level and it meant
that the doctors and scientists vaccines
Ali also theorized that monkeys spread
the cordyceps back in episode 2 so maybe
it was a three it was episode three so
maybe it's just coming full circle from
that now here they find a map with a
location Saint Mary's on it it shows
where the fireflies have moved to but
it's interrupted by some Raiders who
arrive at the location the attacker
brings a baseball bat with him which is
a weapon you'd often use in the game
Joel strangles him and breaks his neck
which is also a movie could pull off
when you grab people in this position
nice little detail is that Ellie has a
gun drawn here and is ready to shoot the
guy like how she did with Brian I texted
you about this yesterday because I'm
actually I just played this level at the
University of Eastern Colorado it really
bothered me in the video game when he
fell onto the the rod and got impaled I
mean Ellie had about 20 seconds to help
him when he was like struggling with the
guy before where he fell and didn't help
him at all and it just it I get it they
had to get him impaled but it's just the
way it was executed actually really
bothered me oh really I don't remember
it specifically it's the first time it's
the first time I really noticed I'm like
I counted actually I'm like I got to
about 15 to 20 seconds like why did
Nelly jump on him stab him like I'm not
saying she had to shoot him just to at
least stab him some it didn't help him
at all and that Ellie in the game by
that point is already like yeah he's
already been killing yeah I've been
doing a lot of like she's done a lot of
killing at that point whereas here like
she was trying to shoot but didn't want
to hit Joel so it makes sense and then
he gets stabbed like this makes a lot
more sense it's a lot more plausible and
does not bother me at all so I still
prefer in the game though having to
sneak out yeah because there was a build
up to him getting injured I agree with
you but I prefer him getting stabbed
versus falling onto that Rod because I
also when I every time
[Music]
obviously probably didn't get any major
organs but still especially with uh the
loss of blood I mean getting out of
there so much blood slamming his head oh
yeah there's no way he would have
survived that and she clearly has an
angle where she can yeah because she's
pushed up against the rail yeah exactly
make it out but y'all ends up falling
off the horse which ends the episode
like how this chapter does in the game
Joel's worst fear has come true and he's
now left Ali in a very vulnerable
position at this point we hear an
acoustic version of this song never let
me down again if you cast your mind back
to episode 1 then you might remember
that we heard the Depeche Mode version
of the song playing over the radio at
the end is spelled danger
by the way there's a clicker right there
I haven't had that pointed out with a
friend that ended up letting them down
which is of course reflected in Joel
here now his fate is left up in the air
and if you want to know what happens and
we'll be tackling it in our superstars
yeah I'll talk about that first before
going into detail on the other spoilery
Easter eggs so you can check that out
after if you want or if you just want to
know if he lives or dies then this is
the bit for you you're still here don't
Joel me hey all right let's go so Joel
is still alive belly has to go out and
hunt for food and Medicine while C
recovers in the game you don't learn his
fate for at least an hour and it was
agonizing playing through it not knowing
what was going on now during this time
she ended up finding a buck and it
managed to get away whether she tracked
it down but this brought her into
contact with David
seemed like a nice guy but he was a
[__] nightmare because he was a
cannibal yikes now they may be the ones
who were past the river of death scary I
immediately thought of oh definitely
double said bodies were found in the
river and that some of these were
infected whereas others weren't the
cannibals could have potentially been
dumping them in the river and they may
have traveled down past Jackson who just
decided yeah we'll steal our reputation
might be wrong on that but yeah that's
just what I thought and when we're
hearing that warning now the constant
mention of the sheep farm is a clear nod
to part two in that Ellie and Dina
actually end up having three pointed
this happens after they failed to kill
Abby Ellie gets constant PTSD flashback
serif gel's death and this location
being samiadi wanted to do is clearly
going to be something that will inspire
the show's Ellie Ellie also brings up
Sally Ride around the campfire in case
you don't know she was the first
American woman to travel into space on
part two we get a flashback in which
Jill takes Ellie to a museum for a
birthday and they look about the NASA
exhibit and the Tipsy bison is also a
big part in this second game after Ellie
learns the truth about the fireflies she
decides to cut gel out of her life but
the pair of course both still live in
Jackson they have a dance at the bar on
which he kisses Dina for the first time
dude the bartender throws some
homophobic slurs away bigot steps in and
punch them and this is when Ali starts
to forgive him now speaking of Dina it
is possible that we see her spying on
Ellie when that's not possible
and it's a big love interest for the
character in season two obviously that's
Dina do you think that that is going to
be the actress exactly the same thought
I was like I look at a Cassie laying
this exactly the same thought I was
having really curious about that I mean
it's not the end of the world if they
like cast someone else I mean but I'd be
curious to know what the audition
process was for because it's easy to
it's easier to track down someone who
looks like Dina but did they give her
actual lines to read so that way they
can keep her for season two yeah that
would be my future but that is exactly
the thought of something I wonder if
they'll keep her yeah we also get the
horoscope mentioning a secret admirer
which could indeed be her because
horoscopes are definitely real and
always always and this leads us into the
tour scene in which Tommy talks about
using his rifle to headshot the infected
refill Ellie asks if he can take a
shooting and at one point yeah
that part is so much fun sniper rifle we
also have the fact that the
interrogation technique jolies said the
star is something that she does in part
two the way this situation plays out in
the game is
the more gruesome approach as well later
on Beyond this we have Maria talking
about betrayal and Joel somewhat does
this with Ellie in the end he lies to
her about what happened with the
fireflies and she chooses to accept this
lie because the truth's too unbearable
to think about is also the giraffe
picture in the room which wraths
foreshadow the big giraffe scene that
happens just before they reach the
fireflies and really quick to the music
that we got when Bill and Frank and
their their final scene when they were
walking after they had their meal and
their wine with the uh all the with the
pills and stuff that they had the music
that we got from Gustavo santalalia that
was the music that they had from that
scene with the giraffe so I just wanted
to quickly point that out they're
located at Saint Mary's hospital and we
see this on the map that they discover
at the University lastly Tommy says
there's a place for them and the pair
both of course end up in Jackson after
the events of part one anyway that
concludes the episode he forgot it you
forgot [__] you forgot okay here it is I
forget the exact line it's still gross
yeah that's what Ellie says it's still
good it's still gross and in the Left
Behind Riley offers to drink and she's
kind of being pressured into drinking
but uh Ellie is you have a choice to
accept or reject the drink if you accept
it Ellie does not like it whatsoever and
it's clearly a call but saying it still
grows it immediately made me flash to
that moment in the Left Behind which you
then pointed to me and said do you
understand that reference which I had to
keep a cool head like yes I did Paul
dude this whole video this whole video
45 minutes waste of time is what I say
and also too I mentioned that I was
going to talk about that picture with
Sarah that Tommy showed in the video
game that we've seen we didn't get here
in the town of Jackson it's pretty
obvious to me at least and we talked
about this off camera after the last
after this episode I'm pretty sure that
Ellie is going to bring up like she did
in the game she's gonna bring up this
she has that picture in her possession
now on the show and she's going to bring
that up and show it to and give it to
Joel she's going to be interesting
because we didn't get that scene here
but again if you've played the game you
got the Gap filled there it's going to
be interesting for people who have never
played the game and didn't get that
scene uh just like where did you get
that from but you might have a line of
dialogue from Ellie saying Tommy gave it
to me or I saw it it was in Tommy's room
or something and I swiped it or
something so I'm kind of curious to see
what the explanation is how she got it
because we know that in the game I think
it was uh Tommy gave it to her my memory
serves me correctly but yeah you know
what would be better though is if when
Ellie does give him the photo so she
cuts out Sarah's head and it takes a
photo of herself and puts it over
Sarah's body as like you have a new
doctor
that would not be insensitive
so much stronger and more emotionally
impactful yeah and that's how you please
audience since we are on the spoiler
really quick since we are on the spoiler
talk we got so much foreshadowing for
part two which I was so happy to get I
was just a little bit mystified that we
didn't get like just a quick Cameo too
of Jesse I thought maybe we were gonna
get a little quick Cameo you know who'd
be perfect plan 20 years ago sung Tang
Pawn from Fast and Furious ah wouldn't
have been great he would have been good
yeah perfect yeah I could see that I
could see that I could also see uh
what's his name uh from uh Temple of
Doom uh I don't know if he's in
everything
he could have played it too alrighty
guys well heavy spoilers subscribe to
Paul's Channel he's earned it clearly
look at this look at this despite that
one miss fight that very come on Paul
hey we at least you know what we got to
educate Paul on one thing so we should
be proud of that we're in the wrong
business we need to get into Easter eggs
Easter eggs and breakdowns man we can do
it all right guys well leave your
thoughts down below subscribe leave a
like and hey let's send this with a
Mikhail Linden Mikhail I just want you
to know that if you ever got a cordyceps
infection I would 100
still let you room with me we'd have
like a Shawn of the Dead situation put
you in the back house we get to play
video games together you love the Bond
movies we would watch all the Bond films
together watch you evolve at Sean
Connery stage from a runner by the time
we get to Daniel Craig you'd probably be
a clicker it would be an incredible
experience and you know what Mikhail I
feel like it would make your life a lot
more exciting if uh you went down this
path don't worry there's plenty of
people I don't like that I could totally
feed you because I
I'll get rid of this guy thinks he can
pause the videos now
my turf my spacebar Turf as I call it
I'm an evil evil man
um the kale extremely far from Patriot I
paid for so long dude and uh try not to
get infected and Michaela I want to
recommend a movie to you 1997's Tom
Arnold film known as McHale's Navy
directed by Brian Spicer who directed
the 1995 classic hit Mighty morphin's
Power Rangers
thanks
[Music]